I think we struggle with a healthy
identity because we've never been forced
into the kind of agricultural realities
that that that almost every culture and
cuisine has struggled with over
thousands of years they evolved out of
hardship they evolved out of peasant
agriculture and they evolved out of this
negotiation that peasants were making
with a landscape how can we get
something a harvest out of this this
soil this landscape and how can we make
it nutritious and delicious for our
family and our community that's the
history of cuisine actually the
exception is America I mean we we never
were forced into that negotiation
because well we're a young country and
also because when the settlers came over
here they came to the Garden of Eden I
mean you you drop a seed and the soil
here and then you have you know
incredible harvest anywhere we have
rainfall you have temperate climates you
have this unbelievable soil when you
look at the history of this you start to
understand that our poor eating habits
in America some of our health diet
related diseases and problems associated
with with poor eating stemmed from just
a history of poor eating the expression
eating high on the hog is really an
American expression because it's about
having me the the wealth the agriculture
wealth to just eat the loin and the
Tenderloin of an animal and and to
because of the abundance be able to live
off that and and that's not cuisine
that's you know if you look at any of
the great cuisines of the world they
don't allow you to eat that seven ounce
protein the steak or chicken breast or
fillet of fish twice a day seven days a
week that's that's an American
phenomenon when you look at the
the cuisine that Japanese cuisine you
see you know a rice culture will you
also see that that to get that rice they
needed buckwheat to grow the rice and
buckwheat into rice was was a was a
famous rotation well what did the
Japanese do with the buckwheat in this
country we feed the buckwheat it goes
into dog food or it goes into bag feed
for chickens in Japan it becomes soba
noodles right and so to eat in Japan is
to it'sit's it's to eat a lot of rice
but it's also to eat soba noodles and
that becomes inculcated into what it
means to be Japanese because it's an
agricultural necessity and it becomes a
gastronomic necessity as well or
cultural necessity well we don't have
any of those kind of negotiations in
this country every cuisine does we don't
and so we're the exception and what you
learn from studying those other cuisines
they have this advantage of history
that's tethered to an agriculturally at
reality that we never face the real
advantage of American cuisine for the
future because I think we will land on
on a cuisine but it's going to be hyper
regional it's gonna be you're going to a
certain part of the United States you're
going to eat because diners are
increasingly demanding this they're
asking for what is special about this
place what is unique about this place
and how can we through a plate of food
or through a meal experience what it is
about this region that's so special and
that's where restaurants and chefs can
play I think a big role